in any question like this it's really
handy when you've got lots of pieces of
information to write down the
information as you go and then you can
put together into an equation that will
help you okay so let's read it together
calculate the total cost that's the
first thing what I'm after is a total
cost okay
that's worth writing down because they
will ask you all kinds of different
things right for instance later on
they'll ask about profits or a total
amount obtained or all these different
quantities you want to know exactly what
you're calculating number one 600 shares
so we know what those are
a market price of four dollars and sixty
five cents okay you're gonna be riding
my compress a lot so I'm okay if you
abbreviate brokerage there you go that
there's that fee that the stockbroker is
charging is 2.5 percent okay so now
we've got all our information how do we
combine it together right well the easy
part is just how much do all of the
shares costs all together that's a
simple calculation isn't it what do I do
how do I get all of this year's when I
buy more therefore 65 piece and I'm
getting 600 so what should I write down
okay calculator right so you get that
out this is gonna give you a number yes
to seven great I can't you can verify
that right now that's the first stage
that's how much the shares themselves
costs now I have to work out what the
cut is okay so I would write down
brokerage and it's a 2.5 percent so I
want that as a decimal so I can stick it
into my calculator 2.5 percent as a
decimal is 0.025 isn't it not point two
five be careful so that's the two point
five percent times now it's over the
whole transaction right namely this okay
so times two seven nine our data give us
but oh we go you wanted as a decimal
right so make sure you press your SD
button if you get as a fraction I'm
getting so you know dollars and seventy
five cents yeah cool so if that's what
this part of transaction costs and
there's the cut well the question was
total costs what's incurred by you well
it's the sum of those isn't it okay this
Plus this and that looks to me like
it'll be two eight five yeah it tends to
be annually it tends to be annually but
but depending on the company like for
example you might have heard big
companies don't release quarterly
reports right and the reason why is
because they'll pay out quarterly so it
depends a little bit on the size of the
company the value of the shares yeah
these kinds of shares very small if you
buy shares in like Apple bit hundreds of
dollars each right so it kind of depends
on all those kinds of things annual is
pretty normal though okay all right now
you might be thinking like this every
single time hmm the short answer is nor
what am I looking for as a marker right
if I would say did this person get this
question right or not this wouldn't be a
one mark question because there's quite
a lot of work into it I'm not just
looking for this number I'm looking for
how was constructive right however if
you don't put these bits down
particularly you working out total cost
you can really get yourself into trouble
and not know where you get went wrong
okay I'll give you an example have a
look down the page actually over the
page let's have a look at number seven
again let's walk through it with my web
okay
calculate the amount obtained great
that's the first thing I amount obtain
so this time you're getting money you're
receiving money not paying it
okay you're not incurring a cost you're
gonna get some money back out of this
right we want to work out how much again
contently its attorneys yes and we're
selling them at tools forty-six apiece
so that's the market price forty-six
like price okay brokerage this time it's
a flat rate so that's nice we don't have
to do any real calculation on that okay
so now again I've got myself here now
I'm gonna work it out just like before I
want to work out what's the total
quantity that I get from all of those
shares right so I'm still going to do
that in much the same way 600 by the
individual unit price no problem what do
we get
no decimal places cool
they go fine so that's how much you
stand to make as profit but the burka
takes their cut don't they're right so
when I write here
well I should say throughout the total
when I write the amount obtained okay
I'm not adding these together I'm not
adding them you get this that gets
handed to you but then you have to pay
the break-up so you don't get all of it
you lose that's when you're not okay
it's such a subtle difference yeah
what's that 647 there you go okay little
little difference but can you see if you
don't understand what's going on you put
these numbers together in the wrong way
you'll get something completely
different at the end make sense okay
let's move on to yield because we talked
about that before
let's have a look at 15 okay again let's
get the important information right
dividend ten cents each
okay there's my first piece of crucial
information the shares have a market
value right the price of three dollars
ten okay market price okay now what was
the idea to get the dividend to you or
the percentage yield I'm just gonna say
yield okay it was to get this as a
fraction as a proportion of this right
so if you go back to where you brought
this all down like just a broken page it
was a dividend divided by market price
right that's what we wrote down yet so I
can do this in two ways
I need them both in the same units right
I can do all in sets that would make
this three hundred and ten cents or I
could do a bullet knowledge that would
make this zero point one dolls ten pence
right so either way is fine so long as
you get the same units I'm gonna go for
sense because I don't like this was a
bit discriminatory like that sorry do it
end over by the price that'll give you a
fraction I want a percentage like so
okay so you reach me calculator okay
wait a second now
point zero so if you just do this pot
right you'll get your zero point zero
three to two and so on when you multiply
by a hundred that will give you your
percentage right so that's three point
three points now did they ask for a
rounding - for any they didn't did they
let's did it do it to two decimal places
that's pretty safe
okay that's pretty simple
did you notice by the way I could have
gone in Reverse I could have gone to
reverse for instance I might have said
what else should we do let's do this as
a separate example underneath suppose I
said to you okay
the market price was three dollars ten
that's what you got before
okay and you get given maybe you've read
in the yard you know the company's
annual report the way givings our yield
a percentage yield of let's call it say
5% it was a good year
okay five percent yield so you wanna
work out well actually how much money is
that for me
okay how many cents am I gonna get off
each share how do I work this out it's
still gonna use this formula but it's
gonna be different
any suggestions before we wrote this
right yield equals dividend over market
price that's what you did right so this
time instead of this being unknown we
know this might we know this and we know
this this is we're trying to find so I
think I heard you're gonna have yeah
it's give me a swap right you're gonna
have 5%
yup right the dividend is what I don't
know
that's what I'm after right and then
you've got your
so how do I get this what's gonna happen
I want to make the dividend subject okay
so it's gonna be yeah the three rows ten
is gonna come over here I'm gonna
multiply by that right so it'll actually
be five percent of three dollars ten
well that makes sense doesn't it you
calculated that'll be point nine five
cause you put it as a decimal and then
what do you get I think you're going to
get will it be zero point so that would
be this is cents isn't it right so so
that would actually be sixteen cents
we know because they're not gonna pay it
off percent so that's the way the works
can you see you can use this equation I
mean we could do this again I could tell
you the percentage yield and the
dividend and you have to work out the
market price okay in fact if you turn
over the page to page 196 you'll see a
table have a look at um question 21 for
instance okay you've got those columns
their face value market price dividend
and yield yield dividend market price
there's a three pieces right they ask
you to fill in the gaps of this table
all they're looking for is for you to
put the right values into the right
spots and install that's it
very simple